and the three finalists for the European
Parliament 2015 sakharov prize for
freedom of thought were ya raised by the
way yeah nobody's javanese William a
young lieutenant chop the prize
established in 1988 is Parliament's not
to those who fight for human rights and
freedom of expression but this year's
finalists have been chosen with a clear
message the supported democracy it shows
the real hot spot of this world some are
already touting Saudi Badawi as the
favorite he was arrested in 2012 and
sentenced to 10 years in prison and
1,000 lashes for speaking out against
the role of religion in the kingdom but
also Boris neum self the former Russian
opposition leader he is it was a voice
that wasn't just stifled he was
assassinated in Moscow in February this
year theory still swirl over who really
killed him but could the Parliament also
bestow the owner on the Venezuelan
opposition the Democratic ug round table
formed in opposition to President Hugo
Chavez in 2008 over one thousand seven
or eight in trial 70 are in jail and the
deaths of 40 killed in protest remain
unaccounted for it's a clear message to
sweet spots in the world that European
Union stands for values and this point
for human rights and follow the offend
people in such countries so you could
fall in the footsteps of last year's
winner Congolese gynecologist Denis
mukwege a the political leadership of
the Parliament will decide upon the
winner at the end of October with the
prize ceremony taking place in
Strasbourg in December
my tips to